china is flexing its muscles as a global
superpower
and not just where you might expect it
it's been spending billions of dollars
transforming the infrastructure of an
entire continent
building ever closer bonds everybody in
the equation wins zambia wins china wins
china has even placed its only overseas
military base
in africa that gain in influence has
alarmed china's rivals our competitors
clearly seek to convert soft and hard
power investments into political
influence strategic access and military
advantage just how worried should
america and its allies be
[Music]
in the 1960s zambians were celebrating
independence from the british it was a
time of hope and freedom
to open up trade routes they had to
build a new railway line
it was a monumental infrastructure
project the tazara railway
and it was funded by china
it was the most expensive infrastructure
financing project that the chinese had
ever done there was a boost for china's
image and influence
on the continent
[Music]
in the perception of developing
countries and countries that were coming
out of the colonial experience china was
seen as a partner to work with in
instances where the west wasn't
interested
tazara was only the beginning by 2022
china had helped lay around 6 000
kilometers of railway lines across the
continent amongst thousands of other
urgently needed infrastructure projects
it has built roads in mozambique
hospitals in the republic of congo
a dam in sudan
since 2007 china has financed more
african infrastructure than the next
eight overseas lenders combined
but all that investment comes at a price
much of it is financed by loans
african nations total borrowing from
china since 2000
is almost 160 billion us dollars
[Music]
angola ethiopia nigeria zambia and kenya
account for half of that borrowing
though all but a few countries owe
something to china
and much of it to state-owned chinese
banks
[Music]
and there's more than one way to call in
a debt
africa is a voting bloc of over 50
countries of the united nations that is
a significant block and the chinese have
exploited this they've used this to do
their advantage as best as possible
in recent years african nations have
regularly backed china on mass
in 2020 53 countries issued a statement
supporting china's crackdown in hong
kong
almost half of them were african
some believe this diplomatic support is
driven by the debt these countries owe
china
and the supposed control this gives it
they have lured african countries into
what we call debt trap diplomacy china
has
extended leases on critical
infrastructure like ports and airports
you have to imagine that if you were a
chinese rival
and china was going around the world is
getting significant boost to its
influence by providing infrastructure
this narrative that china was actually
trying to entrap its partners was a very
very attractive one
it's a view fueled not by facts but
suspicion
the terms of many of china's loans to
african nations are shrouded in secrecy
china doesn't produce reports and and
documents on how much money is lending
where the money is going that kind of
transparency is not characteristic of
the chinese system
in the rare cases where researchers have
been able to uncover information it's
clear china plays hardball
all revenues from the entebbe airport in
uganda for example are used to pay the
chinese lender who helped build it
before anyone else
angola is repaying most of its loans by
guaranteeing oil
in 2020 61 of its oil exports went to
china
whilst china has never tried to use its
loans to take control of the
infrastructure it's built
it is strict about being repaid in full
some western institutions by contrast
tend to be a little more accommodating
[Music]
there are more conspicuous signs of
china's growing power on the continent
in 2017 china established its first
overseas military base
into beauty
staffed by over a thousand personnel it
looks like a direct counter to the
presence of america and its allies just
a few miles away and it's looking to
expand
u.s intelligence agencies believe china
wants to build a new base on the other
side of the continent in equatorial
guinea
china has been arming the continent too
from armoured personnel carriers in the
central african republic
to it appears drones in ethiopia
china is selling military equipment to
more sub-saharan african countries than
anyone else
china's presence in african civil
society also continues to grow
and with that presence comes growing
influence
63 of africans think that this is
positive
in ghana less than half do
my name is bright aqua and i'm an artist
and i'm basically having an exhibition
on the streets of accra i put these
posters up about a month ago
in ghana there are claims that china's
political influence
keeps anti-chinese news stories out of
the spotlight
bright makes satirical cartoons
and displays them where everyone can see
we selected this particular site because
it's a very very popular space
and so
visibility is very very high
bright's story starts in 2016.
back then there was outrage in ghana
against chinese migrants who were
illegally mining gold
a practice known as galam sei
the mining has severely polluted water
supplies but the ghanaian government was
doing little to stop them
currently look at where i'm standing the
land has been destroyed i admire all in
the name of god
as an artist i thought
you know i could use my
my voice to speak to the issue he made
this piece
you see the ghanaian delegation on their
knees
and chinese presidents pouring out some
dirty water
to them i put this painting up on my
social media channels and someone from
the chinese embassy saw it and
a press conference was held and the
chinese diplomats
in the press conference
tried to impress on the ghanaian
government to check literally check the
media and check
the artworks
the claim was defaming their
leaders
it's not the only example of china
exploiting its connections in an attempt
to limit criticism
in 2018 a south african journalist had
his column taken away after writing
about china's treatment of the uyghurs
a chinese company had a 20 stake in the
publisher he worked for
its name
independent media
the style of reporting has definitely
changed and a lot of these stories i
don't think they make it to
the mass consciousness anymore
now china is making bolder moves on the
african media landscape
hello
my name is papastar times star times
enjoying digital
life
star times a chinese digital tv operator
has an ambitious vision to give millions
of africans access to satellite
television
distributing its hardware across the
continent
this deal has been one of the very
controversial ones especially regarding
how much influence start times is going
to have with regards to
what is seen what is not seen on our tvs
and how much that goes on to dictate how
people actually see the chinese here i
think it's it's an issue that borders on
our democracy and perhaps even our
security as a
as a country
in just over a decade star times has
become one of the leading digital tv
operators on the continent
with 27 million online users
its service carries hundreds of african
channels
affording increasing control of the
digital airwaves
while star times develops africa's
broadcast infrastructure another chinese
company is transforming its telecoms
although perhaps not it's advertising
[Music]
thanks
the local people would like to have the
best station up and running before the
range seems to have got a deadline and a
challenge but don't worry we can do it
africans have largely welcomed huawei
and its development of the continents 4g
internet network
as far as china is concerned what we saw
for mining companies what we saw for
construction companies we're seeing the
exact same thing now for tech
financing
undersea cables
for digital infrastructure
transient has the largest share of any
phone manufacturer in africa that's the
fear
that the chinese might use the
construction of the telecom systems to
spy on african governments
and as an extension spy on western
governments that are doing business with
african governments i think that concern
is legitimate but i think
in a place where
the options aren't as many
or as price competitive i think the
chinese will continue to play a very big
role
the seeds china planted in africa
decades ago
have spread deep roots
today chinese lending may be slowing
but its power and influence over society
and politics on the continent will
continue to grow
western concerns are inevitable and
understandable but all too frequently
western policymakers forget that african
leaders and people aren't just
bystanders
this idea that africans are sort of
bamboozled
and and sort of tricked
into accepting a deal that that is
actually not working for them
infantilizes africans and somehow they
need westerners to come and defend them
from the shifty and
in tricky chinese
rather than worrying about what china is
up to in africa perhaps western
governments should spend more of their
time thinking about their own
relationships on the vast and vital
continent there has to be a reassessment
of how the west sees africa and africa's
place in the world
because as far as the chinese are
concerned
they think africa is going to play an
important role in the world and they
should be active in africa one hopes
that the west can
can adopt the same attitude and not
simply pay attention to africa because
it is a target of chinese influence
hi i'm gaddy epstein a journalist at the
economist my colleague john mcdonald and
i recently wrote a special report on
china in africa you can read that by
clicking the link and don't forget to
subscribe